good morning
everyone and welcome to this talk about
functional programming and web
applications uh web application in this
context in the con of this talk is on
the server side uh you can do client
side applications with f shop as well
with a product called Fable but that's
out the scope for this
talk um but if you're interested in that
you can just talk to afterwards and I
can show you the two right
directions uh before I go any further
how many of you know
F almost like half and how many of you
know uh
Suave like 10 something like that okay
that's good good to know uh my name is
Tomas Johnson it's my Twitter hand
handle there so if you have any
questions afterwards you can ping me and
I try to answer as fast as possible and
you can also like raise your hand during
the talk and I try to answer questions
during the talk as
well um I work here in Oslo at a company
called be um where I'm a manager but
that's just a label I consider myself be
a developer as most of you
guys uh I'm also the practice lead of
those net group at
Beck and um yeah that's we do
basically uh my customer I work for is
in the public sector so we I was say
last year talking where I said I want to
do like 90% F programming in in 2016
that didn't happen I may be up to like
40% uh but it's a long process to take a
whole customer over to to FP and we have
one project that's 100% F and we trying
to bring in bits and pieces to to other
Solutions solution as
well uh when I'm not working or relaxing
at home I'm also the lead of net User
Group here in Oslo and also the
initiator of the Uso FP group here in
Oslo so if you want if you're live in
osow there's a Meetup for you
here uh I'm also a Microsoft MVP and
a f Enthusiast at the
least
so what is fshp and why should you
care uh the first part of that the
question is quite easy to answer uh f is
something that came out of Microsoft
research but now maintained by the F
Foundation uh it's a totally open source
project so everyone can contribute to to
FP uh SARP so it's not like net where
Microsoft is actually uh owning the
repos story it's it's a foundation
that's owns the
fpos it's a functional first language
based on the MMO uh language tree and it
runs well on the net
platform uh with that it means both on
the CLR mono and also on net
core uh net core is still on the like do
core is not ready yet so it will will
work on core when it's
ready so that's what f is so other part
of the question is why should you
consider F I'm going to have like a
really short uh introduction to why you
should before I go into the
demos uh F has a really strong and solid
foundation I compare it usually to to C
when I'm talking about this and and one
of the first thing is this really strong
typing compared to to C which mean that
it's if it's compiles compiles it most
likely
run uh but that doesn't mean you don't
have have ever errors of course you can
have errors in in application but you
don't have any like stupid add at
least the next thing is is doesn't have
any null support I have null support
because I have on the net but default
you don't use null in F and tonar who
introduced null in al65 called that his
billion dollar mistake and if you start
thinking about null it's really hard to
reason about it they take a regular C
list for example what does null mean for
a list is the list empty or did the
method return the list fail or what
what's what does it mean that makes it
hard for a developer to actually reason
about
that and if you want to use null in in F
you instead use a thing called option uh
which specifi that this can be a null
and it's much more
explicit the next thing about the making
a Sol solid foundation is it's immutable
by default and that also makes it much
easier to reason about the code because
you don't change the state all the time
instead you just copy the state to a new
variable uh that might sound like it's
really expensive but uh there are really
smart things in the compiler and so so
it's not that expensive sound of course
when you need to do like really hardcore
performance improvements then you might
need to do use on mutability and asop
has support for mutability as well but
that's not
default or it's not how you should do it
if you do it
correctly um and there's also really
good uh syntax support to for example
set properties on a data
structure uh the next thing is
structural equality compared to C which
only ref referential equality uh stru
equality Compares all the values inside
the data structure object or what you
like and that that makes it much more
more easier to know what equals mean uh
if you're doing like equals in in C you
basically basically need to know how is
the equals method implemented for that
object to know what that actually
means uh and this is as long as you use
the F types that's defined in F and not
using any c
types the next thing is composability
this is one of the most important
Concepts in FP um you can compose both
types and functions really easy and that
can take you from this mess of Lego
bricks to a this nice terrifying death
star uh the thing is you can compose
basically anything in most languages but
the question is how easy it is to
compose things and in F it's really easy
just to create simple small types and
put types together to make a whole data
structure and it's also easy to compose
functions together with tiny small
function together with a small
composition functions we're going to see
some example of this later in in the
demo um and you don't need any boiler
plate to actually do a lot of this
work uh the next thing is the feedback
and what I mean feedback I mean in three
different levels the first one is
actually like a social level the
ecosystem in in FP is really amazing uh
it's a lot of open source project the
community is really welcoming and
helpful and there are like super smart
guys and and if you ask a question slack
Twitter or wherever you always get an
answer quite
fast the next level of feedback is when
you actually start sitting down in code
then you have this reple read evaluate
print Loop which makes it easy for you
to prototype things and try things out
out really
fast and that's also a concept that's
actually C it's not a concept from from
F but C has and and rle now which not as
powerful I guess it's a bit nice bit
more
colorful at the moment but but FP is has
had this since day one
basically and the last part of feedback
is testing of course you can do testing
in C uh and other language is but when
you're using a functional language you
use to structure a code differently that
makes it easier to test the code and
that way you get better feedback I think
and that's at least my experience of
using a functional
language so the next part
is f SHP functional language and the web
that sounds a little bit odd but we'll
see that about that later uh I would
like to say that um all applications are
functions and that means that web
applications also are
functions um but what what do I mean
with this does anyone agree or
disagree no
one um let me think about the mental
model of how most people see look at a
web
application of course you can divide
this server box into multiple layers and
factories and providers and controllers
Etc but if you look at it on the Black
Box you us have a request and response
and you have something in the middle
basically so let's move around Arrow a
little bit uh now we start switching the
mental model from you have a request you
throw it in a server and Out Come
response the the one that's making the
request could easily be the same one
consuming the response but now we have
it on different side and this is
actually exactly what a function
is and this is most like how most Lang
most application work and we see it like
quite often now with all the JavaScript
framework coming out like adting this
model like react and things like that so
so yes so if you start thinking about
what is an application the output here
can be right to a database or show some
HTML or whatever so so this applies
basically to all applications as I see
it um and that brings us to the last
part I'm going to have a lot of demos or
hopefully if they work um but first I
want to cover the last part and that's
Su uh this is
a this a project started another a
Swedish guy called Henrick Feld and uh
it is
a really super light web framework
implemented in FP for f and it uh as I
said lightweight nonblocking and it also
runs on Linux USX and
windows uh and that's just it runs on
all platform that's because it's F and F
runs mono so that run on on all those
platforms uh Ive tried it on both
windows and mono and it's no problem at
all I also tried it a little bit in do
and core but just firing up hello world
basically uh so I will work on N core
when it's ready they have some alphab
bits that's running on net core I won't
show that today but they have they're
working on
it um
and you you can actually program web
application using aset and f as well but
the reason what you should care about
saave is saave is a framework
implemented for f which make it much
easier to use Ematic F when you are make
program web
applications so let's go into detail
what uh Suave
is I see Suave as three concepts the HP
context something called a web part and
then we have combinator
so the first part which is the HP
context that's basically just your
request and response object which a b
and also headers and everything that has
to do with a request and response that's
something they have encapsulated in this
data structure called HTP context and
that was passed along through a series
of different steps and all those steps
are web
parts and web
Parts have a function signature that
looks something like this it takes an
ATP context and outomes
a async computation question with a
maybe an HTP context it might not return
HP context it might return none instead
of some HP
context and this makes it really easy to
compose web Parts together in different
ways as we're going to see later and to
compose things web part together we have
combinators and this come this have
basically two
flavors this one that creates web parts
from primitive values making like take a
string and create a web part from a
string or take a function lifting up to
create a web part from that
function uh and also as one that takes
multiple web parts and create a single
web part uh see everything here is a web
part and that makes it also easy to to
compose and and extend and extend the
the
applications so the model how it
basically work is first you start with
some functions or values this is a b
them up approach of how it works then
you apply a combinator on that function
of values to create uh one or more more
web
Parts uh and when you have multiple web
Parts you can use another uh
combinator to create a um new web part
and that's this is basically all there
is to it and of course we can plug in
more web Parts in other web Parts things
like that so so this is really flexible
and really nice architecture to work
with and you can wrap this web
application
to another um combinator to apply some
cross cutting concerns
I think that's basically all I have
about slides today because I want to
show the code instead and see how it
works any questions so
far then uh let's go to the demo and
before demo I also have two other
product that you might see during the
the the demo I won't talk about them but
they're really awesome both for C
developers and F developers it's called
packet which is a packet manager that
using the new get format but it's not
resolving the package references the
same way as packet as as Nate and then
we also have fake which is a build tool
for basically anything um and that's
something we we use both of these tools
in in my
project um yeah that's all I have about
slides start with so let's go to the
demo uh I thought I'm going to do this
uh you can run f as scripts and you can
also Run f as compile application and
since this is just prototyping I want to
show how things work quite fast and I
thought scripting would be nice so I'm
going to do everything as FP the
scripts uh and the first thing we need
to do to get started with
with f is to add s to our solution if
you like
uh I'm using the alphabit because I'm
hardcore um this
actually I submitted a pull request for
one small function that I needed for a
thing and that's why I'm using the
alphabit uh I could almost has used a
regular one
bits uh and this is uh how you define um
new get references in in
pet and to
install
uh this we need to run the
packet
install now just pulling down the S
bits that's basically same thing as new
get
install but the the good part with this
is that I now don't have an inversion uh
number in the path to um to the dll so
if I upgrade saave everything will still
work without me need to update all the
references and then to just create a
hello world we first need to open the S
module and then we can just start web
server with a
default uh
sa sa configuration this is where you
can apply your own configuration or
extend this one to to provide ports and
host them Etc but I'm just going to use
the default configuration uh this
doesn't compile so I need to add
a successful thing that's to get this
okay here to okay is a combinator that
takes a string as input and creates a
new web part so this is basically all
the is to it
hopefully
[Music]
to uh
get
started and this
is that's not Chrome here is
Chrome Local Host I think 83 right so
that worked and that's this this is one
of the most beautiful things about S I
think compared to for example ASB net I
don't think you can
write maybe like three lines four lines
of code dep how if you count the first
one and create a a a uh a hello world
application in aspnet for example so
it's really low barrier to get started
and it's really easy to to build on top
of this and that's what we're going to
do uh now so
let's put this in a
own uh variable let's call that hello
we're going to have a lot of Hello
things and uh
instead call this app and let app
hello
to and now we going I'm going to
implement a a web part from scratch to
show you there there's not that much
magic going on behind
this uh okay keyword here so if you
remember remember from the slides the
signature of a web part looks something
like
this
so this mean we take I think the one
more one too many context that's more
like it so to create a web part we need
something that takes a context as input
so let's take content inut hello now
hello to now take a context I don't
really care what context is uh and now
I'm going to cheat I have some Snippets
so I don't have
to do some stupid mistakes and this is
basically all you need to do to create a
web part and this this a is a
async uh return type we need to wrap
this in a async block that's the first
thing and then we just create a new uh
string and take the bytes out from that
string and add that to
the uh response type response object
here and then we just update the context
uh with that response and returning some
and we returning some context mean that
this web part actually executed if it
return none then this web part will be
skipped so if we now then we also set
that app is equal to hello 2 and then we
is running app which means we now should
go hello get Hello World instead of
hello NC so let's do
that
and that worked as
expected any question so
far quite clear that's good
uh
What uh here uh this is
basically taking
[Music]
the let me do it like
this
let instead to make it it easier to
see so here we're actually taking the
the context that was input and we take
that context make a new copy of it but
set the response uh property on that
context to be equal to the new response
which we created over here and we do the
same thing for the response we take the
response from the context and update the
content property from that response and
create a new
response the question was
yeah how what with in in F
is I actually think there might be some
simless syntax coming
for uh C in the next version as well
because they're going to do they are
working on getting some more immutable
structures into
C inspired by
this um as you see I'm I'm switching
back and forth between this
uh uh console here and that's sort of
annoying so I'm going to cheat a little
bit to so I don't have to um restart the
server every single time I do a change
so let install um fake which is
the the build automation tool I talked
about earlier and we also need a
compiler
service and then I ask then I have
prepared a small or I haven't prepared
this I copy this from thas Petri who is
a really awesome F developer uh which
basically listen on my file changes and
reload the server every time so I don't
have to uh restart a server manually and
I think we're now going to run
on uh 80
33 here you actually see also this stuff
how
you update the configuration if you need
want to use another configuration for
for
Suave
uh but this is sort of out the scope of
this talk but there's no magic going on
and if you're interested in this script
I can point you to it uh before I can
run that I need to
um uh install the package as added to um
packet dependencies and there is support
for that in atom which I'm using uh
through the II project so I both have
now both have packet integration and I
can also use
fake directly
so that spawn thing is a Target in my
fake uh project which now is going
to uh create a new and that won't work
I'm pretty sure
uh because I first have
to let's stop that right away I need to
comment thing this thing out because not
now my build script is starting a server
I want I don't want to start a server
twice so now it should
work this
turns yeah so now works you start up the
browser for me as well uh okay but this
is not as good because I can also go to
this address and it would sort of work
so how do I limit myself to just uh how
do I apply routing to in Suave so that's
the next step um let's continue with
this hello uh part and to apply routing
in in Sava use a use combinator called
path it tells me an error right now but
we're going to fix that uh and let's go
to Hello
to and the the path combinator takes a
string and returns a new web
part uh and to combine two web Parts
together together you use this fish bone
operator
um and to add those two in scope you see
I have some red squiggly lines here we
need to add the pathor and they are in
the in the Suave that filters
module and now I get a new error because
the fishbone operator is not there and
that is in open S
I think it's operators yeah so basic
what this does is if my request matches
hello to then run the path or then
run uh the combinator or the the web
part which I combine with this uh path
hello to web
part so if you try this I still would
get now we get some seror that's as
expect expected hello to
now returns hello
world okay that's good
um but now next step is I want to have
multiple uh paths I also want to
support uh this of
course hello
one and to do that you use another
combinator called
choose which basically takes a list of
web part and
execute the first one that returns
sum and if we try that now we should
have still hello to should be able to go
to
hello but this shouldn't work that's
also as expect
expected so now we have like the really
basic routing going on uh The Next Step
would be to add parameters to the routes
and um to do that you use something
called a pass scan operator or
combinator and we use hello 3 which we
don't have yet and then we just used um
string formatting rules in F sharp to
specify what the parameters in the URL
should be so this is going to match
anything that has a load three to start
with and Then followed by a string
followed by an
integer and this Co uh combinator takes
another web part as input here I don't
combine them together instead this path
can take a web part as input well not
actually a web part it actually taks a
function that returns a web part as
input and that function
must uh support this these two variables
here and here we have the message and
let's call it
index and now I just
return
okay
hello let's move
that there's nothing magical on here uh
L3 takes a message and index that
matches those two parameters here and I
just print out those two into yeah to
the response
stream and if we run this I hope this
should
work
L3 yeah that worked nice so this is this
is almost as As advanc It Gets in Java
that's actually beautiful part of it
doesn't get that much harder than this
and we could also use of course we
instead of error we can just not
found uh combinator
what and that's in
the uh I would actually get if I use if
I using wish Studio I would get some
some kind of intelligence helping me
adding these uh
modules U but it's not that hard to
figure out by yourself and i' like why
don't we use this fish
forell for which one for the hell 3 yeah
the question was why does we do the
fishbone operator for hello 3 uh that's
basically
um the P scan
operator
uh must takes a function in that accept
those two arguments if I was adding one
more argument here
um yeah then I has to have one more here
basically to make it compile and you
can't do that with a fishbone operator
since the fishbone operator operates on
on web Parts but the passan needs to
have a function accepting that
format and now we also have a a not
found
part so this should actually work now
because yeah I added that part but if I
have a string here it doesn't work
because it's bound to an
integer uh okay so let's do some more uh
like relevant stuff uh you make these
parameters optional as well uh true that
was a good question I don't think
actually you can do that not with the
scan at
least uh be quite hard because what does
it mean if maybe this parameter would be
optional uh that that would be I would I
would actually think say no and I think
that's a good thing if you want an
optional parameter there should probably
be a a query parameter instead of
something in the
route um since that's yeah and then you
can be
optional um so let's apply some logging
to this um uh application uh this is too
much code for me to to write all by
myself so I cheat
again but it's not that much code I
have yeah 13 lines of code something
that I think um this is my simple loging
framework H you can imagine that this is
a log framework that would uh print
things to maybe some analytic server or
whatever but I was going to print it to
the console instead and the way it works
is first I have a function called log
which
basically uh print something to the
console and then just return uh a new
web
part and then I also have some helper
functions to to log time to log a URL
and then I have two other helper
function to log start time and end time
just to um that also use the long time
helper
functions uh and then the
actual combinator so this is the this is
how you actually would Implement a
combinator yourself basically and the
combinator here is is log request and
this Lo combinator takes a web part as
input and then we're going to start with
the log in time log URL and
then uh execute the web part that was
passed into it and then it's going to
log the end time of that
request and the reason I have error here
is because the uh compiler doesn't know
what this type should be yet so I I can
help it out like that I didn't have to
because I know I'm going to use it later
and then the compiler will figure out
the type of
it uh and to use this web part this is
basically if you remember from the slide
we have the whole big web part and then
this is what we get get here but now I
can start wrapping this into other web
parts for combinators so now if I do
logging log
request uh that's all we need to do to
add logging for every request in our
application uh I'm actually going to do
that on the console because it easier to
see so I'm going to stop it here
first and then
[Music]
run here
instead so now I should I got some
logging yeah start request at some time
and to
yourl and if I go
to Hello
to I get a new
request okay so that's good but now
let's say you want to extend this uh
loging thing to also
supplyer
[Music]
um it might be a little bit hard to
actually
track uh track the request in this
loging let's say we we have a a sleep in
this request that takes a
while uh and now we
run hello 2 and hello one it's a little
bit hard to know exactly which request
ended when uh so let's add a a request
ID to
everything uh and we start with the
logging function now it's going to take
a request ID as input we print out the
request
ID
and the compiler says is something is
wrong so let's add request
ID
and
ID probably here too and as you see uh
FP
is uh sort
of uh nice to me in in the sense that it
tells me exactly what to do in the
compiler and I don't have to add this
parameter to all the function as well
because I'm using par applications to
build up the structure so if I don't
provide all parameters in a function
call I'm just going to get a new
function
back uh and see log URL doesn't have
request ID parameters I have to add it
there
okay this thing might seem like
a easy thing to do but I wanted to show
this
because uh this a bug in
this uh you see every request got the
same request
ID and does anyone maybe know why or you
want me to tell
them uh the thing is that this this log
request thing only execute once and and
that mean we got the the request ID on
the first time and then it returned this
web part and this web part is what's
used every single time and the request
ID was already bound at that
time and to uh fix
this we could either do as we do up here
take in the context as a parameter to
the function it makes it um then we can
actually handle it ourself or we can use
one of three helper functions in Su one
that's called varer I don't know
actually what that does the other two
are context or
request uh and the context and request
are almost the same all those three are
basically the same
thing uh but they
are um the request is working on the
request object while the context is
working on the uh context proper as
input to function uh I really don't need
the the value so I can just say that
this is going to be a value long care
about that's why I'm providing
underscore uh
and now this is going to return a web
part that's executed for each request
and we should now get a new request ID
for each
request and that
worked
so that's how you apply a cross carting
concern in a SW application that could
also be like authentication would be
probably as easy as ADD ing uh logging
and I could actually apply this
to to just a part of the application if
I wanted to I could do it there I think
so if I call hello to now we wouldn't
get any
new uh any new requests but if I call
this one here I should get some login
part so that this is the the comp the
composability part of suave and FP in
action it's really easy to
move around pieces and and and put
things together to to build a whole
application so let's do something that's
um more real uh I was thinking about
doing a
small sort of stupid web application
that's going to take a input of a city
and a date and return the population of
the country for that City that year and
the temperature that day
that makes sense right um so let's see
see if we can manage to do that in less
than 20 minutes it should be quite
doable so first we need
to uh add uh some serialization helpers
so I'm going to use Newton and we also
need to
use f data which is
um data library in F that has a lot of
type providers I'm not going to go into
detail what type provider is I'm just
going to use them here and and show you
how it works
basically so let's add these
two we
packet uh that's working fine uh and the
first thing I need to do is
actually add some
references this is just the loading the
DLS
uh for me uh just it's not that fun
to to mention um that's what you need to
do to both have uh json. net and and F
data in
scope so the first thing is to add a j
simple Json helper that handles
um uh Json response and and uh requests
uh this is actually the reason I use the
alpab bits of SAA because this part map
Json with was not in the 10 bit so
that's something I submitted to a couple
months back uh and this is how
you uh add a sterilizer
for uh Json in in
Su um first I take something
that encode bites from yeah
is important to be consistent call
things UTF and then ask if to be
sure and then I to have two helper
functions one is D seriz and one is
seriz and the map Json WID takes those
two function as input creating a
new uh a new web part that's going to
take a Json request and return a Json
response and this is something I'm going
to do when I now Implement my
API so let's create a temp pop API temp
pop stands for temperature population
API
um I think it's first thing I need to
have some
types uh the weather typ here is
something I get from the Json provider
is F Type provider and uh this is a
sample request that
returns some kind of
response know what uh and then I also
use the World Bank data which is also
from the s data Library so these are two
type providers that that generate the
types for me while I'm actually
developing and then I have this uh
request type here I want to have a
string as input and a datetime as input
to to my API
uh and I'm going to return the request
to see yeah I want to return request uh
the temperature uh the population and
the country everything here is optional
because you you don't if you ask for
2016 you don't get a response for
population because we don't have the
stats for 2016 yet I don't think you
actually have it for 2015 in World Bank
dat either uh so let's implement the
population
function
uh get
them population uh this is probably the
most advanced thing I'm going to show
you
uh the population
take a uh a response object and check
the country and also check the gear of
the of
the of the date to actually go and then
uh ask the World Bank data for the stats
for that year so World Bank data
have uh typ Ro here has some really
awesome things so here I can navigate
through this is like real time going
through the the API to data and looking
all the countries in the world I can
navigate through here and and find
some nice stats about each country so
what I'm doing is uh first finding the
country
I'm interested
in uh and if I did find a country I'm
looking up the indicators for the
population total uh if I found found
that population indicator I'm just going
to set the population to to the result
here so that was the population
part and the next part would
be see uh the
temperature
uh this is a little bit
easier uh here I'm
using EXA to the same type provider as
here but this was a sample request and
now I need
to uh
actually this should be uh percent s
yeah there it
is so that that's the parameter to uh to
the the function I'm using and I you can
see it up here somewhere here I using
Oslo instead so that's how I figured out
how that API worked
um so yes doing the request for that URL
and I got get the we API and the
response object looks something like
this this is something that F Type rer
generated for me and then I just
converting it to Celsius because I don't
have no idea what farite is um and then
also
extract the count from this from this
response actually and using this later
on to get the the
population and to put these things
together uh we need to have
the I think that's the function yeah so
here I'm using the the previous Json
helper uh the map Json net function and
in said is takes a response object which
now has a signature of get temp pop and
that's the what the the helper function
here do for us and the f
um type system help us with to figure
out and then I start with an initial
response setting the request to be equal
to R and setting everything else to
nonone and then I just pipe this
response or response through those two
functions filling filling out the data
that the I found in in the in the
request
uh and to add this here we need to do a
I think it's
PA
API temp Pop I
think and here of
course uh I need to do
not where is Postman here here
Postman so response should look
something like this and if I'm lucky
this should work right away it did yes
so uh this date was 8°
celsus I think and uh population
in 2014 was 5 million people in Norway
and that
is
there was all there is to it basically
like 50 lines of code maybe uh to uh as
two apis parse all the data and get the
result result back from them and also
plug things in there's one thing more I
can show you and that's let's say that
we only want to
use uh post as we do we do Post here but
this should probably work with get it
doesn't make sense because you shouldn't
get data this way
um but let's do a post instead only
support post and that's this is how you
do this
[Music]
in in Suave so now you're selling this
this route should only supp support the
post U action so if I'm trying to
get data I should get some kind of what
because this doesn't exist and back to
post it should
work yeah I think that was all for my
demos I have short
summary
um so the first part is f SHP is awesome
I hope you saw that and um feel that
you're a little bit interested in trying
this out um of course I was only using
the scripting part because I wanted to
prototype and show show things out but
it's not that hard to actually move this
to a console
application uh if you want to but you
can actually host a script application
if you want as well there there are
example of that hosting fop script
applications in as your website for
example uh we can run it in Docker
um but yeah depending on how large
application is uh you should probably
use a compile application but for
prototyping and trying things out it's
really easy to get started with a
console application or or a script
environment and and just write those
three four lines of code and you're up
and
running and the next thing is the web is
functional as everyone agreed
on uh so try to program the web using a
function language because it is
functional uh if you want to know more
there are some resons here here you have
sa um
there's you can always go to GitHub and
look at the code it's not that advanced
code actually uh if you have any
question how a combinator works it's
almost easier to go look at the
combinator in the in the code than
actually trying to read the
documentation uh and there's a free book
on git book that's a great introduction
to Shava as well that took a lot of
inspiration from uh and all my C code
samples are in the last rep over there
uh it's a kind of mess on that repo but
the code is there at
least
uh before I take questions uh the next
talk in this room is going to be Scott
lashin he's going to talk about parsing
I guess that's going to be even more
advanced than my talk uh so please stick
around for that and there is also on the
PCT is the lab hour that is right after
lunch where you can come and uh ask
questions for all the functional
speakers here at the
conference and with that any
questions no hosting in excuse me what
hosting in I is that hosting in is uh
was a question I think that that that
should be should be possible but not the
same way I should do with espet uh
because the the example that I think was
Scott hansan who did it together with th
pet host in the script application
on as website that is actually running
on Hood I guess so you can fire up uh
exe and host that in is process but I
would rather actually run it just as a
console application I I did a small
performance Benchmark to against saave
against. net corbits on cell and it's
roughly the same uh performance wise on
my mission it did I didn't do a huge
performance Benchmark but uh I don't
think there's a good reason to use is
for that maybe as a should probably use
like engine X or something else on top
of of sa instead of
is any other
questions for for example if someone
sends corrupt requests try to sort
of I think I would actually if you're
using internally in then you it might be
fine but for public I would probably put
it by behind engine X or H Pro or
something like that the question was if
it's safe to expose to the public and of
course you can but I would probably put
it behind a proxy
yeah yeah up there yeah thank you very
nice nice
presentation I just to add the benefit
to the audience
that pretty Lowel way of working with
the web there
are which will allow you to do
everything both on the server and side
and you get the benefit
of URLs and
so so the comment was that there's are
this also project called Web sharper
that you can use together or separately
with
sa that gives you some more more stuff
basically little bit High more high high
level than
Su any more
questions then thank
[Applause]
you